we had shirtless Tyler see we had Jesus
still loves me Jesus still loves me and
we had the windmill grease is the woman
that's right mrs. your bachelorette
recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and Rose Day I'm
sorry for that everybody I'm Lauren Zima
and the fantasy suites have come to us
and they were even better than expected
weren't they
it's like when you get something and
it's really good and it totally lives up
to all of your hopes and dreams and then
you get it a second time okay what did
you think of fantasies we'd let me know
in the comments below in honor of this
unforgettable episode of The
Bachelorette I am drinking Chardonnay
not rose day today but here's why I am
drinking a $70 bottle of wine I won't be
eating this week but I don't care this
was such an amazing episode that I had
to do it justice I love cake bread wine
this is not an ad I just love it it's
expensive but it's a really good
Chardonnay let's all indulge a little
bit we deserve it
Hanna deserved it too and she did
got it okay so we are in Greece and
we're starting off with a lot of looking
round shots that is looking around and
Peter's looking around all Peter's first
okay and Hannah straight-up says that if
everything is on the up and up with
Peter she's ready to get down gonna get
down I want to drink for every time we
have clarity this episode because Hannah
got a lot of clarity didn't she and
Peter gives us the sailboat hey guys
it's me
I had to vlog about Peter here's the
thing I'm sure you've seen ETS interview
with Peter's ex-girlfriend and she makes
some claims about him but we've got like
two episodes left and I just want to
freaking enjoy this show so I'm just
talking about the episodes as they are
and I also do still have questions for
Peter just like I have questions for
Jenn and have issues and questions and
lots of thoughts for Luke so all will
come in due time until then here we go
so we've seen this coming in the
trailers but god it was glorious wasn't
it
the clips in the blue waters and the
sunshine
and a lot of good s words with Peter and
this episode so I want to drink for
every good S word but please drink
responsibly there's one big s where it
isn't there
sex sex is the S word I'm going to say
sex it's what could say sex I've
stripped down every wall that I ever had
Peter also has an S for stubble on the
sailboat he's going five o'clock shadow
going on and I like it what did you
think of Peters newfound facial hair I
was so worried that Peter was always
kind of looking like a fourteen-year-old
boy could even grow facial hair turns
out yes
as for stubble drink if I could get a
picture with you in this like background
Wow and I'd be like my screensaver on my
phone forever
we get an unexpected S word screensaver
I didn't see Peter bringing that up but
screen savers are sexy too there's so
many moments where I kinda just want to
like get up and scream and as for scream
Peter wants to scream we know he loves
to howl yeah and maybe he did some
Howlin one or two times okay dinner I'm
thinking Peter just say you love her we
heard you say that you were in love with
her on hometowns to your mom but not to
Hannah yeah Cheers and drink every time
Peter is so close to saying I love you
and I am this is um so when we were
flying also asked for sunburned Peter
got quite sunburned did anyone else
notice that his cute little red stubbled
face you know leave it some sunscreen
SPF I'm sorry because I better stop I'm
just trying to say s words down maybe
realize
and then he says it Peter loves Hannah I
was shocked he didn't howl but we'll do
it for him so that seals the deal for
Hannah she is like I need that time with
Peter I just need that I'm all in if
you're in I need that and oh my god they
are walking to the windmill peter is the
windmill peter is the windmill peter is
the windmill in the fantasy suite
I am a windmill were you guys happy
Peter was the windmill oh my god I'm in
my mic Gordon I gotta sit down this is
grease isn't the one who's right Peter
says grease is known for windmills and
it is now oh forget the Greek gods
forget Greek food windmills Siri how do
you say windmill in Greek I can't
translate into Greek yet Wow The
Bachelorette is ahead of its time drink
every time they say windmill it's the
[Music]
and then oh my god one of my favorite
things they are breaking the fourth wall
again heaters okay that was not me to
sneeze we're gonna close this time
proving something I've heard from Leeds
before that there are condoms available
for you in the fantasy suite as there
should be and this camera work oh my god
they are zooming in on the condom it's
dying
and we have the warning actor and you
know we usually have some questions
about what goes down in fantasy suites
but not this time it's time we know
exactly what happened and how many times
it happened and seemingly let it happen
safely that's know asks for shaming here
just an esper sex and then as for
standing with Dan Hanna wow I've already
gone through almost a glass of wine on
the Peter date but again deserved I
wonder how much of that glass cost me 20
bucks whatever we're indulging it was
the best day of my life so it's the
morning after and some of the wording
here Peter says they quote came together
we came together like it's so much last
night and Peter is in sexy drawstring
sweat pants I love when guys wear that
look and Peter likes Ana so much doesn't
he in fact he loves her I loved with
Hannah we've heard him talk about how
he's never felt this way for anyone
before and I am s4 scared I'm worried
about Peter getting hurt because his
feelings for Hannah do seem really
intense Peter and Hannah don't end up
together
will he be crushed okay any leaves with
a backpack heading to perhaps another
windmill will there be a third time okay
so now I'm thinking who's gonna be next
who can top that
oh I know Tyler
Tyler is looking a little T for tan and
R for rift and I am V for very excited
about it okay mmm-hmm and then I'm kind
of shocked by what Tyler says he says
he's ready to propose to Hannah yeah I
don't really have any questions the
words of down some more I'm just ready
to propose and get down on one knee and
be her man but we haven't even heard him
tell me he loves her yet do you guys
think Tyler's ready to propose let me
know in the comments below then we're
having a massage moment with Tyler and
we've seen this in the previews but like
this whole episode it was even better
than we Tyler actually participates in
the massage and Hannah is so into Tyler
and we see why the sexy is jumping off
the rezident I'm watching this movie
whatever it is whether it's Sun each be
O or an Oscar winner or on xanax or our
streaming or something new and
independent film the documentary I'm
watching this okay I'm 1,000% sure
that's is going to see what Tyler is not
an issue and I want to drink for every
time that Hannah says a smart thing
about sex this episode she says that
honestly her and Tyler have an
attraction but they need to work on
their communication I feel
scared about just how far our physical
connection can go when our emotional
communication needs to catch up
sometimes and that if he is her forever
she has forever to be intimate with him
they don't have forever to be physical
with him like I don't want to go into
fantasy suite and have sex and then we
drink for clarity Hannah tells Tyler
very clearly I don't want to have sex in
the fantasy suite
um when Hannah is telling Tyler that
she's not ready for them to sleep
together he looks so stay perfect
don't drink forever es wird I'm not
trying anymore no I'm trying not to but
it's difficult
a lot of s words like see the wine he
looked frightened as if he was worried
but maybe she would break up with him we
have to say a few more s words because
Hannah says that Tyler wants her to be a
strong woman he makes me feel strong
because he allows me to be the strong
woman that I am and
he celebrates not boundaries yes ask for
strong and s for supportive because that
is the man that Tyler see be let's
remember though that Hannah still hasn't
told Tyler she's even falling for him
she also didn't tell Peter that the solo
person she's told that team is Jed what
do you guys think about Hanna's feelings
for Tyler
I think her feelings for Peter are
stronger I'm worried with Tyler that
it's mostly a friendship / physical
attraction I'm ss-scared but then things
get even better than we expected we
already knew Tyler was a supportive man
of a strong woman and in the morning
after Hannah says that Tyler is quote
the most respectful man she has ever
been with he used the most respectful
man's ever been with me ever ever
I'm asked for spent ms for shutting down
a mess but so obsessed there's a lot of
ass isn't obsessed Jesus oh we're gonna
get to Jesus
he's coming later so new drinking game
drink for every backpack Tyler leaves
with a backpack also like can we get
these men like a tote bag or a rollaway
carry-on or something like these these
backpacks are weird and like watching
him just leave me from our date like it
rips me
oh god and Hannah says that things with
Tyler have ripped her and not just
because he's ripped
okay now much like last week this is
going to be a very different second half
of the episode from the first last time
I saw Hannah I honestly felt pretty
angry oh now it's time for Jed I need
some clarity Lube okay so right off the
bat Jed is crapping all over Luke again
and Wow
who would have thought I would feel
defensive of Luke yeah that's the power
of Jed I guess got me over here feeling
sorry for Luke wanting to say stop
talking crap about Luke who would have
thunk it
so Jed and Hannah are like out with a
local family and there's music and I
wrote down please God don't let Jed sing
again luckily this episode was better
than expected that didn't happen
Hanna acknowledges that she is only told
Jed she's falling for him who and Jed is
jafer jealous as he says that Luke is an
elf rely on me why let me give you an
eye for I find it ironic that you're
saying that Jed but trust is like the
number one thing ya says that Trust is
the number one thing number one thing I
think a relationship has to be built on
a relationship has to be built on and
she makes a toast to honesty being able
to be honest let's go I asked her the
core it kind of says a lot about your
decisions Luke comes up again and I am I
am so tired of Hanna having to tell
these guys that she is going to deal
with the Luke thing herself then Jed
takes a real turn and is now questioning
her very ability to make decisions
period worried that you have a hard time
letting go of things that aren't good
for you in your life damn maybe you
should turn that questioning around to
yourself jet
I got a look in a mirror try to see
myself a little clearer it's written in
the stars but I shouldn't let my eye get
this far and I need the drink
me too I just think in a first second
and Hannah is up and she's gone and
there is crazy camera work of following
her by the way you know what Hannah
didn't have an opportunity to bring up
at this dinner with Jed his other
relationship because she didn't know
about it he's have to let me figure it
out Hannah says to Jed that her feelings
for Jed have nothing to do with Luke
understand how it's frustrating and I
wonder if Jed was using that same
justification in his mind about his two
relationships it's the morning after and
another backpack I just - is an
important number isn't it things in the
windmill twice
Jed's number of alleged girlfriends -
and I was thinking more and more about
why Jed brought up Luke twice on this
date and I kind of wonder if it was a
bit of a distraction my theory is that
Jed was maybe gonna try to tell Han
about the girlfriend thing and maybe he
wanted to bring Luke up to really drive
home that Luke's the bad guy here not
Jed liked to make himself look better
what do you guys think why did Jed keep
bringing up Luke now we gotta go to Luke
when it comes to confidence going into
this week I'm so confident I know that
she knows I'm I'm the one all right Luke
gets to go to Santorini and that just
doesn't seem fair because I think when
we think Greece we think about Santorini
the blue domes and the gorgeous moment
saying Luke that's that really Luke said
he was honored to go to Santorini
honored and I wrote down yes you
freaking should be and then the sex talk
is happening talk about sex oh god we've
been waiting for it all season long no I
want it yeah you know don't drink for
just when Lucas talking because he's
just talking so much and Hannah's doing
such a good job listening and Luke says
that sex is an incredible thing yes
terrible thing it was like and Luke says
a lot of things always know when it's
timid within the guidelines of the
marriage
throughout which all of them Hanna's
like mmm-hmm she's just doing so much
good listening I was so impressed with
her composure with her grace if I if I
if you told me you're having sex or you
had sex with one or multiple of these
guys now I'd be wanting him to go home
we're drinking for clarity Hannah is
very clear she says quote some of the
things you said some of the things that
you said I don't agree with at all like
I don't agree with it at all he says if
she had sex with any of the other guys
then he would leave for sure look that
on its own is Luke's opinion and it's
fine honestly like Mike I'm mad but
Hannah then brings up a bunch of freakin
incredible points she was a GD superstar
lawyer in this moment she gave him
exhibits a B and C you're way out of
here Lou
and again three stance let's break it
down
Hannah calls them out Luke starts
backtracking so I do want to take a step
back he makes really strong statements
and then backtrack Solomon doesn't own
them Luke you can feel the way you want
to feel but you gotta own and stand by
your opinions man you just said them own
your words okay
the closest thing that I've ever felt to
will love at first sight was probably
with you by the way explaining someone
for connection with Luke Anna says that
things with Luke were nearly love at
first sight he did get the first
impression rose but we have broken that
Bachelorette curse by this point for
sure yeah I was like okay I want to talk
to you but you know what as usual with
Luke the conversation gets convoluted
and confusing
but this is what is critically important
Hannah tells Luke I have given you so
many chances I could have asked you also
many times from being my husband's and
things that I want
I have looked past many of your flaws
for hope that we could evolve together
like well I want somebody who can get
along with people it doesn't have
parties but you just said out loud that
you would cut me off if I didn't live up
to your standards and that it's just sex
for you and that you're like if you've
had sex that I'm going home
that is when District Attorney Hannah
brown played the law what did you guys
think of Hannah's points let me know in
the comments below
Luke can feel how he wants to feel about
sex before marriage but as far as I can
tell hannah has never said that she's
someone who has a problem with sex
before marriage I did find out that one
of these relationships he did slip up
and have sex so Luke's calling it a
slip-up but Hannah's never said she
considers it a slip-up Hanna I just I
can't applaud you enough on this it was
important it was a learning moment it
was masterful
[Applause]
and I prayed so much a clarity and I
feel like I finally gotten cleared you
mean
so now things are crystal freakin clear
as clear as the blue waters of Greece as
clear as that Greek vodka viagra water
drink that Hannah took a shot of Hannah
says quote I do not want you to be my
husband and she sends Luke off but he
won't leave and drink every time Hannah
says come on you guys I don't hate Luke
I don't hate Jed I don't hate Peter
these people are people who are exposing
their lives to the world in their first
time on reality television that's tough
and I want them to have the chance to
speak for themselves when I'm able to
interview them but the biggest thing
that bothers me about Luke is something
that he did again on this episode he
does not respect Hanna's ability to
think and make decisions I'll even share
what you just said to me about you
feeling like that you have clarity on
this I still feel like
you don't so it's raining you know look
the rain has come away to wash things
and to give clarity I can probably get
you to go in that limo it from what you
Syst
na aana has to make the windmill reveal
to get Luke away from Earth so like I
have had six
yeah
you know Jesus still loves me
this episode is even better than I
thought it was going to be from
obviously how you feel me
you know windmill probably be probably
literally
and yes we did it a second time like you
guys our girl Hannah didn't even tell
him that by choice
or to hurt him she had to tell him that
to get him to leave how fresh and riyo
that moment for Hannah and then oh my
god Luke asks Hannah if he can pray over
her
[Music]
see for condescending much Oh
he finally leaves and Hannah grabs her
wine I'm sorry Lord I don't wait to the
lip and she finally figured it out for
herself I finally figured out for myself
she said she would and she did you guys
our girl follows through we stand a
Hannah s first and don't still be
playing that stupid drinking game I came
up with next week on The Bachelorette
and then we get the trailer and all the
guys looks so good I will say as much as
I have questions about Jed I do love
these final three guys friendship
moments especially because we see that
Luke c4 comes back we had seen in the
trailer that some guy comes back with a
ring to propose to Hanna and I had
guessed that it would be Lucas isn't
over for me
and yes it turns out that it is Luke
that he returns with a r4 ring and the
other guys have it wrong with it not
shockingly by the way you guys we're
gonna get the men so long I can't wait
for it
cam is gonna be back we've done a lot of
letter work this episode so good to see
see for cam again me this is why you
don't date TV
at the same time we see the trailer for
the finale and Hannah says this is why
you don't date two people at the same
time advice that would have been great
for dead everybody this has been so much
and let's make a final cheers to two
amazing moments because to a first and a
second that's the critical number for
this episode so I want to cheers to the
window and I want to cheers to our girl
Hannah
I love you guys so much thank you for
being here as always leave all your
thoughts below and this might be my
favorite season of The Bachelorette ever
it's gonna become even more wonderful
now because of a different amazing man
no it's not Tyler see it is JC JC I need
you to walk in here with the outfit that
you're wearing you guys
JC didn't even know what the guys were
wearing at the end of this episode and
how amazing they would look in their
graves and their blues and their Greek
moments look at what this boo boo showed
up to work in today look at him are you
kidding me proud to be JC look how
handsome this man look you are Grecian
you are ready for Greece dapper daring
and you know what a damn good guy I'm
gonna this is very expensive wine but
I'll give you something and then you
this a little bit it's like $10 off love
you guys let's say bye together 1 2 3
bye okay great I've been talking for a
37 hours I'm so sorry guys